welcome to the show everybody we have
what what an eventful night we had last
night we have our first series of a
really important results for the 2022
midterms we had a number of different
primaries yesterday some of the results
are absolutely delightful and some of
the results are absolutely horrifying it
really runs the full gamut and we're
going to get to
all of it two races that we were
following very closely in pennsylvania
the senate race why the senate race in
pennsylvania the senate race in
pennsylvania could decide whether
democrats or republicans ultimately
control the senate starting in january
of 2023 and if it comes down to
pennsylvania
on the one hand we want to know who is
the republican nominee going to be
and on the other hand we also are
following whether trump's endorsements
continue to have value and memit oz was
the trump-endorsed candidate in the
republican pennsylvania senate primary
also
delightfully i was gleefully seeing the
results yesterday that trumpist
congressman madison cawthorne
lost his primary he's out he's been in
office 16 months and he has already lost
the primary and he is going bye-bye so
let's look at this one by one
starting with north carolina's 11th
district
chuck edwards a current republican state
senator in north carolina has defeated
the incumbent madison cawthorn now it
was close edward's coming in with just
over 33 percent of the vote cawthorne
losing with just under 32 percent of the
vote but it nobody's saying it's so
close we need a recount
for now nobody's talking about fraud in
fact madison hawthorne is actually
saying
that uh establishment forces in the
republican party turned against him
because he would criticize those who
needed criticism and all of this stuff
which we will get to but this is
absolutely fantastic news and we're
going to talk about that more in a
moment
on the pennsylvania side
uh starting with the democratic primary
john fetterman
almost literally from an operating room
easily winning the primary john
fetterman as we talked about on the
bonus show yesterday had a stroke over
the weekend ended up needing to have a
pacemaker with defibrillator installed
via surgery yesterday he's doing well he
easily won the reports are he will make
a full recovery and will be strongly
back on the campaign trail fetterman
will be facing the winner of the
republican primary and as of this moment
when we're taping today's show we don't
know who that is all night
trump endorsed republican mehmet oz was
losing losing to dave mccormick and as
the night went on oz chipped away
chipped away chipped away at the
advantage that mccormick had and by the
end of the night by this morning with 95
percent of the vote counted
memit oz is ahead by only 2 500 votes
that's 0.2 percent of the vote as a just
as a reminder
in pennsylvania if the margin of victory
is one half of one percent or less it
triggers an automatic recount these
numbers aren't final
but the point is if the numbers end up
being this close there will be an
automatic recount and we're off to the
races again and we will see ultimately
what the results of that are but we
don't
yet know because they are still counting
ballots now we're going to talk about
pennsylvania governor in a separate
segment it's a very important race and
it deserves its own time
uh but we will get to that in a moment
so madison cawthorne tweeting a
concession uh quote congratulations to
chuck edwards on securing the nomination
tonight it's time for the 11th district
republicans to rally behind the
republican ticket to defeat the
democrats november nominee this november
kawthorne did praise trump when
conceding take a look at this clip
oh you know what the thing that i love
about president trump is that when you
get your back pushed up against the wall
i found that most people in politics
if it's not politically expedient to
them they'll turn your back on you in
the heartbeat
but no matter what you are facing when
donald trump has your back he has your
back to the end
i don't know that i really agree with
that i mean this was politically
expedient for trump to endorse cawthorne
at the end of the day
the guy running against cawthorne isn't
like a wild trumpist and cawthorne is a
wild trumpist so that's the political
expediency just before uh conceding
cawthorne did weigh in on the leaks of
his pictures and videos and all of this
stuff he says it's a coordinated strike
from within the republican party to take
him
there down been several photos and
videos of you circulating on online on
social media recently what can you say
to those constituents who maybe have
lost some confidence in you and and are
looking for some other kind of
leadership you know what i'll tell you
there's been a coordinated strength
carried out by really kind of the old
establishment wing of our party and it's
really something that i think is that
it's a loser's mentality they realize
the direction the country's going in the
direction that the population is going
in uh and if they want to be able to pay
off people from my past and try and
bring up old pictures or things that
happened years and years ago
i feel free to let them do that i think
the american people will see through
that well whatever i mean listen he's
right it was very clear that the
republican party uh establishment
decided we don't want madison cawthorn
to remain in the house of
representatives now his framing is
it won't matter because the country's
going in his direction he lost the
primary he is out and that's an
absolutely fantastic thing voters have
in a sense sent madison back to his room
to think about what he did hawthorne's
loss is also a loss for trump trump went
on trowth central uh he he calls it
truth central as you might remember
truth essential it's actually called
truth social trump went on truth and
endorsed qathorn two nights ago and uh
this one did not go
trump's way so that is a loss for trump
now meanwhile this is just bizarre at
his event last night mehmet oz thanked
fox news propaganda sean hannity make
you proud
i want to thank sean hannity
sean's like a brother to me
when sean punches through something he
really punches through it he understands
exactly how to make a difference and
he's been doing that the same entire
campaign much of it behind the scenes
right giving me advice on late night
conversations again the kinds of things
that true friends do for each other
in another era in the american political
media landscape
it would be outrageous to hear
that
an on-air host on one of the major
networks
was not only openly supporting one of
the candidates in a primary but behind
the scenes giving them advice and pep
talks at one point that would have been
that would have been seen as
inappropriate no no listen you have an
on-air persona
and it wouldn't it's not right for you
to be advising a candidate in this way
without it being really what you're
doing officially you you were
you're doing one thing and then you're
doing another thing behind the scenes
and you're attacking oz's opponent on
air without disclosing that you have
this sort of informal advisor to the
extent we know it's informal advisory
relationship at one point that would
have been outrageous
now we just kind of shrug and go yeah
hannity picked the candidate and was
helping uh memit oz and then on the
other hand dave mccormick who
we still don't know whether it will be
oz or mccormick almost in a in a tie at
this point 2 500 votes separating them
this you have to see
beyond parody mccormick now says
we might still win because of mail-in
ballots which of course the whole line
from the republican party has been
mail-in ballots are bad
mail-in ballots are fraud and now
mccormick is saying don't worry we've
still got the mail-in ballots coming
now we're gonna
we're gonna win this campaign we're
going to win this campaign
and uh and tomorrow right now we have
tens of thousands
of mail-in ballots that have not been
counted that are going to need to be
counted beginning tomorrow
and uh and so that unfortunately we're
not going to have resolution tonight
but we can see the path ahead we can see
victory ahead
don't worry guys the mail-in ballots my
party has uh attacked for the last uh
two years are what ultimately will save
us and this is normal for the right
whatever fits the narrative of the
current five minutes they go with so
those are some races great to see
madison cawthorne defeated that's bad
for trump
we've talked often about the
mediterranean diet the mediterranean
diet one element is olive oil and many
olive oils are adulterated with fillers
other types of oils are made with oils
that are old or low quality
brightland is where you get the good
stuff brightland is a california-based
company offering authentic fresh olive
oils and vinegars made from local
harvests
never over processed no fillers or
artificial preservatives because
brightland only works with small
california-based family-run farms that
don't use harmful chemicals they pay all
workers a living wage every bottle has a
label with the harvest date olives are
harvested early in the season pressed
within 90 minutes of harvest for the
highest quality oil possible brightland
sells an olive oil set called the duo
which i've been using at home it's
unbeatable one is called awake it's a
robust
oil for breads and soups the other is
called alive it's smoother great for
veggies and salads brightland ships to
you in recyclable bottles that protect
against uv light and in sustainable
packaging when you go to brightland.co
pacman you'll get 10 off the duo the
link is down below